I started the RIFE program and supplements mid-December. I've reordered supplements a couple
of times. How long should I continue on these supplements? How do I know if the cancer is settled
down? My next scan is in July. Just wondering if and when we should make adjustments to my supplements.
So I have a video on the member site on when should you do another cheek swab? So when should you
do another cheek swab is when you are wondering whether you should make changes. So but also you do
another cheek swab if you're getting worse or you're getting better and you want to hopefully
get off some things. You can do another cheek swab when you're like when you think you'd go to the
doctor to get rechecked for something. You could do another cheek swab. When you're getting rechecked
for supplements, is it a good idea to do another cheek swab in any specific interval? Well, maybe in
60 days, then maybe three months, then maybe six months, but it would be different if there were
changes. If I'm doing really well, maybe you have the attitude that I'm doing really well and I'm
in remission, I don't want to make any changes. Then just stick with what you're doing. But if you're
doing really well in remission and I want to see if I cut down on some of these things, then maybe
do another cheek swab or if I'm not feeling as well, then you could do another cheek swab.
Now, doing another cheek swab is just going to test for our protocol. To answer your second question,
how do I know if my cancer is settled down? Well, then you have to do some testing. So what are some
testing things that you could do to see if my cancer has settled down? Well, do I just a standard CBC
and complete comprehensive metabolic profile? What we call our complete wellness panel would be a good
idea because there's going to be clues and hints in that if a person's getting better or worse,
barely inexpensive, 250 bucksish, to keep an eye on that. If I like the question before,
if I have anemia, if my anemia is getting worse, that can be a clue that my cancer is not getting
better or if I have different markers in my cup or has a metabolic pedal that are getting worse.
If my alkaline phosphatase is going up, if my AST and ALT, other liver markers are going up,
that can give us clues to different things. Every test is giving you clues to help with
your differential diagnosis as you go through this process and you weigh it out with your subjective
data as well. So getting a standard blood test CBC and comprehensive metabolic profile.
Number three would be getting two markers done. If you have a cancer that typically will show two
markers, that could be a beneficial thing to do. Well, so obvious one would be prostate with PSA,
breast cancer with CA-153, CA-199, 27-29, a CEA. So, and then
Hey, gradic cancer, CA-199. So you could do a tumor marker panel, a female or male tumor marker
panel. I haven't done any of those at all. Well, it might be good to just get that run. So we have
a baseline of where you're at because that could give us clues. Again, nothing's perfect,
but it can give us clues to whether we're getting better or getting worse or staying stable.
And then you get into more detailed or invasive testing like an MRI or CT scan or a PET scan.
Short of that, doing X-rays, short of that, maybe doing ultrasound, depending on what type of cancer
you have. So those are the ways that you would measure our progress. I do a video of that as well
on the member site. I don't know if I'm getting better, I think today, but the video is. So that would
be a good thing to watch. And another video on what blood tests a cancer patient should do.
That would be another good video to watch. So all those things, I think, would be beneficial.